if you go onto the motherboard section
and PC part picker you don't find there
are 29 pages of motherboards with each
page having 100 motherboards so about
2900 motherboards like all these choices
how do you find a perfect motherboard
for you
[Music]
welcome to Haris hobbies now choosing a
motherboard really just boils down to
three different things which are chipset
form factor and other features that
you're looking for the first step in
choosing chipset is to decide whether
your vendor overclock or not overclock
your cpu but this will determine what
chips that you choose if you are
building a budget I to be or Rison 3 or
even I 5 or right and 5 PC you are not
playing to overclock we have a couple of
options AMD does up for a motherboard
series of is not overclock which is to
8320 series but with the price gap
between a 320 and be 350 being so small
I really just recommend you guys jump on
to p3 or 50 series unless you're on a
very tight budget as for Intel you have
three options the h3 70 be 360 or h3 10
if you want to top an motherboard with
all the bells and whistles that come
along nowadays but just don't care to
overclock than h3 70s what you're
looking for if you don't really care
about all the new features and this one
is solid reliable motherboard then be
360 is probably for you as for the h3 10
series the same thing goes as the a320
series from AMD unless you learn in a
very tight budget
I recommend you jump onto be 360 if
you're playing overclock however from
Intel side you're forced to buy a z2
Reese motherboard which correspond to
your CPU which will probably be C 370 or
SD 390 with nd however you still have
several options and this only cuts off
the a320 series Luther is stellar
backwards compatibility - you still have
the be 350 and B 450 and for higher-end
x3 70 and x4 70 unless we were building
a top-end gaming PC with the horizon 7
and the latest GPU I strongly recommend
you guys check out the B Series instead
that
series really there are no big
difference between the X series and B
series the B Series does have inferior
power supply system but for most of you
guys that probably won't make that big
of a difference you will most likely be
able to overclock the same group Hertz
if anything maybe water makers less so
unless there is some specific feature
that you want from the X 370 or X 470
chipsets I recommend going with a PCS
motherboard so at this point no matter
where you stand you have two options
ask for in tow you have the Z to be 70
and z to 90 and foremost AMD builders
the other be 350 and be 450 and for
hiring AMD builders you have the x3 70
and x4 70 and in all of these cases I
would recommend that you go with the
older model because the newer model will
not give you any more performance and
just cost you more money now that we got
chipset out of the way the rest will be
a breeze the next thing to decide is the
monochord size or form factor and this
is pretty simple
there are three main form factors when
it comes down to mondo ports which are
ATX micro ATX and mini ITX with ATX
being the most common you also have
other form factors such as e-atx but for
most people that most common three equal
be enough this is all so reliant on what
case you are buying but is unless you
are a bunch of space underneath your
motherboard and you probably want to
match these two up from a technical
perspective ATX motherboards have the
most PCIe slots and m dot 2 slots as
well micro ATX have a little bit less of
PCI slots and usually only one and AH
two slot do a factor of shorter finally
many I case motherboards generally only
have one PCIe slot and also cut down on
DIMM slots to two but for most of you
guys who are just going to have a single
GPU with 16 gigabytes of RAM and maybe
an MDOT 2 as a boot drive any of these
will really work it really comes down to
how big you want your PC to be are you
building a small compact PC or a big
all-out PC this really does just come
down to personal preference
the smaller motherboards are cheaper
because they are smaller but don't base
your decision
based on that don't forget to think
about the limitations of smaller
motherboards as well such as less DIMM
slots which the main limitation finally
the last thing to do is filter based on
your personal needs and here are some
things that you should not forget to
filter out how many USB ports do you
need and what type are they
what type of ru interface do you want in
your motherboard do you want the
Bluetooth and Wi-Fi card in your
motherboard is your a color scheme that
you're looking for or do you want your
motherboard to be RGB make sure to
verify your motherboard has these before
jumping onto it
and one more bonus thing to consider as
brand choice for everyone I recommend
Asus MSI or gigabyte these are the three
main motherboard manufacturers and you
have really good quality motherboards if
you're on a tight budget
however as Ralph and biostar aren't bad
choice to either
lastly the theories that I would
recommend you guys buy is since chuck
series from Asus
they aren't extreme like the hero
formula or Maximus but they are above
average and come with all the bells and
whistles you can think of and all the
slides that you want and since they are
black and silver and come with RGB it
will fit in with any color scheme and
our color neutral the gaming series from
MSI is definitely also a top pick but
that's just my preference
it's just something crucial darn forgot
to say about motherboards make sure
comment down below so that other people
can benefit from that also if you guys
like this video then make up the like
and consider subscribing if you like to
see more videos just like this one but
until then I'm RT and I'll see you guys
on an excellent
[Music]
[Applause]